يتواصلوا في بريطانيا اذا اضراب عماله هو
الاكبر منذ عشر سنوات بمشاركه نصف مليون
عامل اذا اعلنت 50 نقابات عماليه هي
نقابات معلمي المدارس وثائقي قطارات
والحفلات وحراس الامن والمحاضرين
الجامعيين وموظفي الخدمه المدنيه اضرابا
للاحتجاج على تدني الاجور والمطالبه برفع
رواتبهم في ظل موجه الغلاء
كما تشهد البلاد احتجاجات ضد خطط القانون
الجديد للحد من الاضرابات وقالت النقابات
ان ذلك قد يؤدي الى اقاله العمال الذين
يصابون بشكل قانوني
نهجا صارما حتى الان مع اضرابات القطاع
العام قيلتا استسلام لمطالب الزيادات
الكبيره في الاجور لن يؤدي سوا الى زياده
التضخم
صور مشاهدين مباشره من لندن لهذه
المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه اذا النقابيه
للمطالبه بزياده الاجور في محيط البرلمان
اذن البريطاني
ومن محيط البرلمان
حربلو تنضم الينا ضعينا في صوره المشهد
لديك ابرز الشعارات التي ترفع وهل نزلت
الحكومه على موقفها
مياده المشهد فعلا
عفوا مياده هناك ايكو في الصوت
مياده يعني هذا المشهد اليوم هو مثير
للتساؤلات حول الى اي مدى يمكن ان تصمد
حكومه رشيد امام هذه الدعوات والضغوط التي
تواجهها من اجل عفوا
هناك مشكله في الصوت ولكن
مياده كنت اقول بان هذا اليوم يعني هذه
الاضرابات التي تعتبر الاكبر منذ 2001 11
وهذه المظاهره الاحتجاجيه التي تتزامن
معها يعني تزيد من التساؤلات حول الى اي
مدى يمكن لحكومه ان تصمد امام الضغوط التي
تواجهها على الصعيد السياسي من قبل
المعارضه وعلى الصعيد يعني الشعبي من قبل
يعني ناخبين البريطانيين الذين يتوقعون
منها بان تحل مشاكل في ظل هذه الازمه
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه الخانقه التي تعيشها
البلاد والتي تتزامن مع النسبه التضخم
عاليه هي الاعلى في 40 عاما فقط 10.5 في
المئه هذه يعني الحاله التضخم التي دفعت
بها هؤلاء العمال الى الخروج في اضرابات
منسقه بعد ما ان كانت اضرابات منفرده على
صعيد نقابات محليه او شيء من هذا القبيل
الا انها ادت الى يعني تكاتف الجهود بين
ممثلي هذه النقابات من التعليمه التعليم
الذي يعني نقابه النقابه الوطنيه للمعلمين
التي اعلنت عن سبعه ايام من الاضرابات
اولها هذا اليوم الذي اثر على 85 في المئه
من المدارس بعضها اغرق وبعدها عام يعمل
بشكل جزئي على صعيد انجلترا ويلز ايضا
المحاضرون في الجامعات البريطانيه وحراس
الامن واضافه الى اكثر من 100,000 من
1,000 موظف في الخدمه المدنيه في الوزارات
في المكاتب العموميه الذين توقفوا عن
العمل مما يعرقل عمل يعني الحياه الناس
البريطانيين توقف المعلمين مثلا يؤدي الى
الغاء عدد كبير من الاباء يعني اعمالهم
لانهم كان هناك نوع من الدومينو اف اكس او
تاثير الدومينو لان المعلم لم يعمل اليوم
التلميذ لم يذهب الى المدرسه
هو الاخر لنذهب لكي يرعى اطفاله هذه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي والاجتماعيه التي
والفوضى السياسيه التي تعيشها بريطانيا
صراحه بسبب عدم رغبه الحكومه الاذعان
لمطالب النقيب النقابات والمدربين بزياده
رواتبهم فوق مستوى التضخم او ما يتمشى مع
مستوى التضخم بدعوه ان الحكومه تريد بان
لا تفارقنا لتؤثر على جهودها من اجل
المعالجه التضخم والعوده الى نمو
الاقتصادي وتاتي ايضا في وقت فيه ارقام
الاقتصاديه المثيره للتشائم بالامس كان
هناك بيانات من صندوق النقد الدولي الذي
يقول بان الاقتصاد بريطانيا هو الوحيد بين
الدول الكبرى الذي لن يحقق نمو بل سيلان
كمش هذا العام بنسبه 0,100 هناك نقاط اخرى
مهمه تثيرها المعارضه بين الحين والاخر في
مجلس العمومي هذا كان هناك جلسه المسائل
الاسبوعيه لرئيس الوزراء البريطاني الذي
ساله زعيم المعارضه لماذا لم يستجب لهذه
الاضراب لماذا لحل المشاكل الاضرابات
والمغربين همم ريشي سوناك القى باللوم على
الريش على زعيم حزب العمال المعارضه الذي
اتهموه بتشجيع النقابات والاضرابات وهذه
المظاهرات التي تشهدها البلاد من نقطه
اخرى الحكومه البريطانيه تقول بان تعترف
بان هذه الاضرابات تشكل اضطرابات وتداعيات
على يعني حياه الناس لكنها تعاهدت بان هذا
بانه هناك بان ستستعين بعناصر من الجيش
حوالي 600 من عناصر الجيش الذين سيقومون
بتخفيف الاعباء والاعباء هذه الاضرابات
وتداعيات هذه الاضرابات على حياه الناس في
المقابل يبقى التساؤل هل حكومه
ستصمد امام هذه الضغوطات السياسيه
والشعبيه انها ستواسل عنها
اصابع باذن الاستثمارات
وبين هذه الحكومه في ظل ذلك كيف تبدو
الحياه اليوميه في بريطانيا تحت وطاه هذه
الظروف
اضطرابات وفوضى في طريق مثلا المسافه التي
يمكن ان تاخذ ساعه بنسبه لشخص في القطار
تاخذ مثلا ساعتين بالسياره لان كل الاشخاص
المسافرين الذين يستخدمون القطارات حول
ارجاء البلاد يطرون الى البحث عن سبل
الاخرى وطرق اخرى لتنقل بين المدن او الى
المطارات او الى مثلا اماكن العمل كان
هناك ازدحام في الطرقات ولا زال صراحه في
الطرقات هناك ايضا تعرق الحياه الناس
العاديين مثلا باغلاق مراكز التوظيف
والمراكز التي المكاتب التي يعني يتقاضى
الاشخاص البريطانيون المعونات من خلالها
تاثير على خدمات الجوازات تاثير ايضا على
خدمات فحوصات السياقه قياده السيارات
اضافه الى تاثيرات اخرى
موظف فيها الخدمه المدنيه مياده يضربون عن
العمل يعني كل المراكز والمكاتب العموميه
المغلقه بالك اليوم هناك ايضا اضطرابات في
المطارات قد تشهد عدد كبير من الاشخاص
الذين ربما يضرون الى الغاء رحلات بانهم
لم يتمكنوا من الوصول في ظل عدم توفر مثلا
السيارات الاول القطارات للتنقل الى هذه
الاماكن من ناحيه اخرى المعارضه تصر على
ان حكومه تتجاهل المشاكل كثيره اللازم
يواجه ضغوطات اخرى من قبل في ما يتعلق
بالفساد داخل الحكومه المحافظين بما في
ذلك يعني مؤخرا كان هناك الى همم يعني
رئيس حزب المحافظين همم
الضرائب كان هناك ما زال هناك تراكمات من
جائعه
فيما يتعلق على الصعيد السياسي والتحقيقه
الجاريه مع رئيس الوزراء البريطانيا
السابق برج جونسون الذي قال همم زعيم حسب
العمال المعارض بانه كيف يعقل بان شكرا
الحكومه تتوقع من دا في عقارات بان يدفع
ثمن همم يعني هذه الجلسات للتحقيق فيما
حدث في ابان فضيحه
البرلمان مراسلات الجزيره من حرب شكرا
جزيلا لك